oh hi
i was just reading about the mosasaurus
and lost track of time
if you want to be transported the same
way i was click on the link below
to get our what if 100 book now let's
start the episode
[Music]
roughly 60 million years ago
the largest snake to ever exist
roamed the earth this is the titanoboa
this giant snake hunted reptiles
birds and even crocodiles
so what would happen if this creature
roamed the earth today
how much food would it need to eat
would it be a threat to humans
and how big was this thing
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the titanoboa never went extinct
discovered in colombia its official name
is the titanoboa
serejonasis with a length of 15 meters
and weighing just over 1 000 kilograms
it would be almost three times the size
of a giant anaconda if you're
a person of average height its one meter
girth would be as high as your waist
fortunately or maybe unfortunately
you'd be most likely to find a titanoboa
when
you're both hunting for fish or swimming
it's a matter of physics moving around
in the water is
much easier for creatures like huge
whales
and this snake rather than being on land
and although living in trees has
never been an option for this great
snake it
could trek inland on occasion scientists
are
speculating that it belongs to the snake
family called
boyds they're non-venomous snakes which
sounds pretty safe but titanoboas might
use
teeth to grab a hold of their prey and
it's been said that the teeth can bend
like curved hooks sticking into you the
more the prey struggles
the more it gets hooked then they
squeeze their prey
after a few minutes ischemia happens
blood flow to the heart or brain is
restricted
causing a shortage of oxygen and
eventually
death fossils show that a titanaboa's
lower
jaw extends past the back of the skull
giving it a greater range of movement
when opening its mouth
it could swallow you in one piece
titanaboa probably fed on giant turtles
and primitive crocodiles which were
about
6 meters in length a snake this size
would probably have to eat about 40
kilograms of food
every day that's twice as much as an
anaconda
these snakes are killers that can move
easily in water
humans might be an ideal snack
places such as australia seem to coexist
with
dangerous snakes but the sheer
massiveness of a titanoboa would
dwarf anything we're used to
titanoboas would prefer a hot damp
jungle-like area like the amazon snakes
rely on heat from outside their bodies
to survive
about 58 million years ago
titanoboas lived in an environment about
five degrees warmer than it is today
maybe we'd find these giant snakes in
asia or what about a place like florida
it's sweltering and humid for part of
the year
because of its massive body roughly the
size of a small
car it would most likely hide in hot
swampy areas or lakes this
allows it to hunt more efficiently
alligators lounging along golf course
lakes are common in florida
and the titanoboa could easily be
attracted to this food haven
and if there are no alligators on the
menu that day
what would be the next best option yeah
golfers
i bet you're wondering if there's any
benefit to having titanoboa around
well yeah pest control
raccoons deer or anything ripping
through your garbage would
no longer be an issue with a titanoboa
on the lookout
now although the titanic boa is extinct
we recommend that you stay clear of
giant snakes
in 2018 an indonesian woman was
swallowed by a giant python what would
it be like to be eaten alive by one of
these giants
well we'll leave that story for another
what if
you